on va passer au débat de ce club on va
évidemment parler de la loi immigration
puisque c'est le jour J le texte arrive
en séance cet après-midi au Sénat Gérald
armanin espère trouver un compromis on
voit ça avec Adrien
pin un projet de loi inflammable et
l'hypothèse un accord entre droite et
gouvernement semblait trop point mort au
cœur des dissensions l'article 3 qui
prévoit la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers tention une partie de la droite
demande sa suppression et le président
du groupe er au Sénat refuse tout
compromis cet article 3 c'est un droit
automatique qu'on accorderait sur les
Médes donc en tenstion à toutes celles
et ceux qui ont fraudé si vous faites
une loi où d'un côté vous avez des
mesures d'expulsion que vous ruinez en
de l'autre côté en ayant en ouvrant les
portes en disant on va régulariser plus
cette loi elle ne sera pas capable de
reprendre justement les rennes du chaos
migratoire pour mettre la pression sur
le gouvernement les républicains ont
même lancé une pétition sur
l'immigration mais pas question de
lâcher du l'est sur sur l'article 3 pour
le ministre du Travail l'objectif que
nous avons c'est de permettre à des gens
qui travaillent qui sont intégrés parce
qu'ils travaillent et dans des métiers
qui sont souvent des métiers difficiles
où il est difficile de recruter puisse
être sécurisé et en les sécurisant eux
on sécurisera aussi les employeurs les
centristes acceptent de modifier
l'article 3 mais pas de le supprimer ils
craignent qu'un texte trop dur ne puisse
pas être voté notamment par la gauche
François Hollande est favorable à
régulariser les travailleurs étrangers
en situation irrégulière et souligne que
la circulaire Vals le prévoit déjà
quelque fois on fait des lois on ferait
mieux d'appliquer celle qui existe déjà
ça existe et et tous les jours il y a
des employeurs qui permettent la
régularisation de de sa papier de son
côté le rassemblement national pourrait
voter le texte si l'article 3 était
supprimé il y a en même temps une
posture de fermeté et en même temps cet
article de loi qui est probablement le
plus grand appel d'air migratoire de
toute la 5e républi le ministre de
l'Intérieur géralde Darmanin se montre
pour l'instant opposé au recours au 493
la chambre haute examine le projet de
loi jusqu'à vendredi Pierre Gérald
ramanin croit au compromis hein il est
prêt à discuter des nuits des semaines
est-ce que ce compromis est possible en
tout cas il joue il joue gros he il joue
sa crédibilité gerérald Darmanin il joue
sans doute d'ailleurs sa probable
possible nomination à Matignon à travers
ce texte Elisabeth borne joue aussi un
peu sa sa place à travers à travers ce
texte parce qu'ils nous ont expliqué
qu'effectivement le en même temps
pouvait fonctionner sur un sujet aussi
difficile aussi grave que euh celui qui
est présenté à travers ce texte projet
de texte cet 1e projet de texte sur la
question migratoire et la question de
l'asile je sais pas s'il va réussir à
obtenir un compromis ça semble assez mal
parti
euh la gauche elle-même est assez
sceptique sur sur les mesures très euh
répressive et très euh contraignante sur
la question du droit d'asile parce que
le texte joue sur une terminologie
finalement qui qui qui qui devrait nous
interroger tous d'ailleurs parce que euh
le cœur du projet de loi euh finalement
repose sur la possibilité la
systématisation des octf des des
obligations de quitter le territoire
français et des refus de de
régularisation à toute personne
susceptible de menacer l'ordre public et
là c'est cette nouvelle notion qui pas
si nouvelle que ça mais qui est le cœur
de ce texte qui pose quand même une
question dans en terme de de de d'État
de droit parce que qu'est-ce qu'on
considère être une personne susceptible
d'être une menace à l'ordre public c'est
quand même compliqué euh dans dans dans
les termes du droit de consid une
personne de parce qu'Al aura était la
fille de le fils de d'f c'est quand même
c'est pas ça là vous très bon jusqu'ici
mais mon ch c'est exactement le cœur du
du problème bref pour revenir sur la
question d'orian sur la question de du
compromis possible c'est mieux je je
vois pas très bien comment il peut
trouver un compromis et si le compromis
consiste à faire des cadeaux commeuon
semble vouloir le faire sur la
possibilité d'un référendum de
l'immigration je je je crois pas que je
crois pas que ça je crois pas que ça
soit ni efficace pour pour convaincre
les députés républicains parce que c'est
les députés dans l'occurrence qui qui
don il sera question à un moment donné
même si les sénateurs sont plus
raisonnables au sens de duquel Emmanuel
Macron a envie de l'entendre je je vois
pas très bien comment ça peut empêcher
un refus général de de voter ce texte
compromis impossible Dominique pour vous
aussi pierre a dit
que le ministre de l'Intérieur et aussi
la première ministre Elisabeth B allit
jouer leur crédibilité d'une certaine
façon d'accord mais je vais vous dire
l'ensemble des forces politiques j'ai
envie quand même de distinguer les les
républicains làdedans mais l'ensemble
des forces politiques joue leur
crédibilité face aux Français on n pas
en 4e République on est on est on est de
pourquoi parce que on s'aperçoit et je
suis pas je m'agenouille pas devant les
sondages qui qui qui nous
dicteraient ce qu'il faut penser et ce
qu'il convient de faire mais enfin les
sondages massivement y compris dans
l'électorat de gauche un peu moins qu'à
droite mais y compris dans l'électorat
de gauche mass ement demande plus de
fermeté alors bonne chance à ceux qui
pour des raisons de calcul interne je
veux pas avoir l'air d'avoir approuvé un
un un texte qui viendrait du ministre de
l'intérieur avec lequel je suis en
réalité d'accord mais qui pourrait
donner le sentiment que on a basculé du
côté de de de la majorité sortante alors
que tout le monde a en tête le le la
future présidentielle et les
regroupements qui auront lieu bonne
chance à ceux qui s'égareraient de ce
côté-là ça c'est ce que j'appelle la 4e
République on est on fait les petits
calculs et tout et les Français et les
Français qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez au français voyez même les même
les électeurs de la France insoumise
souhaitent plus de fermeté j'entends
bien que plus de fermeté c'est une
formule enfin c'est une expression et et
qu'il faut voir il faut pouvoir la
décliner d'une façon X ou Y mais
qu'est-ce que vous en fait je je je
pense que quand on fait de la politique
on le fait parce qu'on a des convictions
oui et quand on a des convictions
dit sages conv quand on a des
convictions il s'agit de convaincre donc
y compris si les Français sont
majoritairement favorables à l'pement
favorable à fer politique de fermeté
fermeté par rapport à quoi si si le
débat autour de la question migratoire
était serein sain avec des données
objectives si on arrêtait de dire que il
y a un problème migratoire si si on
arrêtait de mettre le de créer un
contexte très anxiogène tour de la
question migratoire déjà peut-être on
pourrait avoir un débat plus apaisé les
Français pourraient avoir
plus objectif plus recul sur ce qui est
réellement la question migratoire arrê
de considérer qu'en France on est envahi
qu'il aurait une submersion migratoire
comme l'avait déjà dit Monsieur colon
lorsqu'il était Premier ministre il faut
arrêter de penser que l'migration elles
viennent tous parce qu'en France ce
serait formidable de venir de migrer
d'abord la France n'est plus une terre
d'accueil la France n'est plus une terre
dans laquelle on a envie de se dire ah
ben c'est super on a des aides machin et
ceter les gens passent par la France
pour aller en Angleterre la plupart du
temps on va plus souvent en Allemagne la
France n'est plus une terre d'accueil on
devrait s'interroger pourquoi on n plus
une terre d'accueil ça c'est la première
chose la deème chose il faut encore une
fois se dire que les migrations les
migrations de manière générale elles se
font c'est l'histoire de l'humanité et
par ailleurs elles se font du Sud vers
le sud on VO on traverse les pays
pauvres pour aller vers les pays pauvres
donc il faut arrêter de se dire qu'on
serait le centre du monde et qu'on
serait forcément une terre attractive on
l'est plus on l'est pas donc ajouter
ajouter une nouvelle loi et François
Hollande l'a dit dans dans l'extrait que
vous avez diffusé un certain nombre de
de choses qui sont aujourd'hui dans le
projet de loi de Monsieur daranan sont
déjà effectives encore faut-il mettre en
place les politiques qui sont votées par
les parlementaires une chose et vraiment
c'est là-dessus que j'ai commencé mon
intervention tout à l'heure parce que
c'est moi c'est ce qui me c'est ce qui
me contrarie le plus et ce qui
m'inquiète le plus dans ce qui est de ce
qui est le cœur de cette de ce projet de
loi c'est considérer que on va pouvoir
pointer du doigt une personne
susceptible d'être une menace à l'ordre
de l'ordre public mais qui comment qui
qui va juger de ça et bah c'est ça a été
dit dans c'est dit dans le texte ce sont
les préfets qui vont juger de ça qui
qu'une personne peut être susceptible de
menacer l'ordre public et donc
expulsable bah moi cette dérive là
m'inquiète en terme de droit on est
encore en état de parmi les points qui
font débat il y a la transformation de
l'aide médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence est ce que souhaite la
majorité sénatoriale c'est ce qu'a dit
souhaiter également Gérald haranin mais
c'est pas la vie d'Élisabeth born elle
était ce matin l'invité de la matinale
de France Inter je pense qu'il faut
absolument que dans notre pays on
maintienne un système qui permet de
soigner les personnes qui en ont besoin
et qui permet je vous dis de nous
protéger aussi en terme de santé
publique évidemment en s'assurant que ça
se fait dans les meilleur condition vous
nêtes pas favorable de d'une suppression
de la me non non je ne suis pas
favorable à une suppression de la me
alors en pressant on peut changer de nom
mais le principe qu'on peut-être soigné
parce que ça renvoie à un enjeu de santé
publique je pense qu'il est important
dans notre pays voilà vous êtes d'accord
bullshit com quoi c'est le problème de
ce texte c'est que c'est de la
communication bullshitc pardon elle nous
explique on va pas changer la me mais
peut-être on va changer le nombre alors
c'est pour faire quoi on va changer quoi
à l'intérieur non mais ce texte c'est de
la communication on nous explique chaque
projet de loi après chaque projet
question la communication qu'il provoque
chez vous tant de passion tant de
répulion tant deamation je vous dis
pourquoi pour moi c'est de la
communication parce que ce que nous fait
comprendre le gouvernement c'est que le
danger le danger viendrait de
l'extérieur le danger viendrait
systématiquement l'extérieur donc la
figure de l'étranger serait la figure de
l'ennemi de l'intérieur alors qu'on voit
bien en France que la question
terroriste par exemple se sont fait ce
sont ce sont souvent le fait de
nationaux faut arrêter de de c'est pour
ça que je trouve qu'on a on crée
un exrieur c'est complètement fa pour
revenir sur la on a Élisabeth borne qui
dit le contraire de ce que souhaite
Gérald harmanin est-ce que c'est
l'illustration d'une fracture bord mant
sur ce t écoutez pardonnez-moi je vais
employer une expression un peu familière
on s'en fout enfin en tout cas je m'en
fout qui un écart entre la première
ministre et et le ministre de
l'Intérieur sur un sujet cert important
non ce qui se passe c'est que dès lors
que le sujet immigration la thématique
immigration avec notamment par exemple
l'aide médicale d'État que vous évoquez
D qu'il est abordé franchement qu' qu'on
en discute que chacun donne son
sentiment à ce moment-là on voit sans
surprise des points de vue des
sensibilités fort différentes les unes
des autres moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
que il y a une différence entre pour le
moins sur ce sujet-là entre éisabeth
borne et et Gérald harmanin mais Gérald
armmanin et isabeth borne sont tout à
fait différents ensemble de ce que de la
vision de la vision que Pierre
Jacquemain donne de de du débat sur
l'immigration reviens au point de départ
vous êtes revenu à votre point de départ
je reviens à mon point de départ encore
une fois sans m genouiller devant les
sondages ça n jamais été mon cas et et
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fonctionne mais
néanmoins massivement il y a une
réclamation des Français plus de fermeté
plus de clarté je dirais plus de clarté
alors après on le décline de façon
différente d'Illes la preuve sur ce
sujet-là à l'intérieur même de la
majorité relative mais majorité tout de
même il y a deux points de vue on verra
je sais pas ce qui va se passer cet
aprèsmid on va se mettre d'accord
ensemble ça fait ça je souhaite toujours
non mais ça fait ça fait combien de
dizaines d'années ça fait au moins 30
ans qu'on a légiféré en matière d'asile
et d'immigration est-ce qu'on a réglé le
problème à chaque fois on nous a
expliqué qu'il allait avoir plus de
fermeté à chacune des lois chacune des
LO on expliqué qu'il all avoir plus de
fermeté vous trouvez que ça réglé le
problème pierre je vous pose une
question est-ce que pour vous il y a une
question une clarification qui s'impose
ou non ou continuons comme avant ah non
non non moi je suis d'accord avec vous
Dominique tien une clarification qui
s'impose c'est son dire que la question
migratoire est un problème déjà
commençons par dire problème migratoire
la question Mr problème
inversant vous dites arrêtez avec voyons
les choses tel qu'elles sont mais les
problème de la France c'est pas un
problème migratoire c'est un problème de
l'accueil vous voyez qu'en Allemagne on
a accueilli de l'accueil vous voyez
qu'en Allemagne on a accueilli presque
près d'un million de de personnes les
personnes ont été accueiles on éé n'allz
pas trop vite il y a beaucoup de
problèmes actuellement je m'en réjouis
pas mais en Allemagne he c'est il y a
sans doute des problème sauf que 80 %
des du million qui a été accueilli et
aujourd'hui logé travaille estant est en
compagnie de sa famille quand on met les
moyens sur je pas le mot mais sur
l'intégration mais sur la possibilité
que les gens qui arrivent sur un
territoire puissent vivre correctement
avec leur famille avoir un travail avoir
un toit oui les choses se passent bien
il y a pas de raison que ça se passe mal
en France on refuse de faire ça on
refuse de donner les moyens pour
apprendre franç pour loger Domini
répondez juste non mais répondez je je
le convquerai pas mais je veux vous dire
l'honneur de la France c'est de savoir
accueillir des immigrés génération après
génération il y a un nombre considérable
et et c'est fait partie de de l'honneur
et de la gloire française quelque part
euh mais d'ailleurs il y en a qui
continuent d'accéder mais il y a une
situation actuellement qui est la la
conviction de beaucoup de Français d'une
d'une immense majorité de Français que
la situation n'est pas contrôlée hein
c'est on on est on est on est les les
les les arrivées de de migrants se font
sans que il y ait eu un point de vue
français là-dessus les veut--on comment
les accueille-t-on et cetera je je je
vous renvoie pour
je vous convaincrai pas mais je vous
renvoie au sentiment puissant des
Français qui recoupent d'ailleurs un
sentiment dans dans pratiquement tous
les pays d'Europe vous vous voulez qu'on
continue comme avant et qu'on ne se pose
aucune question on pas on
pas vous avez le droit de considérer le
sentiment des Français pour moi le
politique les politiques ne sont pas là
pour considérer un sentiment ils sont là
pour avoir des convictions et convaincre
les Français je suis pour les
convictions mais j'espère de temps en
temps que vous tenez compte de la vie
des Français et on suivra ce débat
immigration ce sera par de 16h sur notre
Anthème on va passer au second débat de
ce club et on va parler de la montée de
l'antisémitisme Alex depuis l'attaque du
Hamas contre Israël le 7 octobre dernier
le nom le nombre d'actes antisémites en
France a fortement augmenté
effectivement le ministre de l'Intérieur
géralde daranin a donné des chiffres
hier depuis le 7 octobre il y a eu 1040
actes antisémites en France 486
personnes ont été interpellées et
précisément dans l'agglomération
parisienne il y a eu 257 actes
antisémites et 90 personnes interpell
sur cette explosion de l'antisémitisme
dans notre pays on va écouter la
réaction ce matin de la première
ministre isabeth born alors ce que je
dis d'abord au juifs français c'est que
je mesure pleinement leur angoisse face
à cette recrudescence d'actes antisémite
on ne peut évidemment pas accepter dans
notre pays cette résurgence de cet
antisémitisme qu'on avait pas connu
depuis des années et on sera intraitable
on ne laissera rien passer les personnes
seront retrouv et condamné donc je pense
qu'il faut que chacun prenne conscience
de la gravité de ce que vivent nos
concitoyens de confession juives se
ressaisissent et qu'on ait ce sursaut
pour dire qu'en France il n'y a pas de
place pour l'antisémitisme et dans ce
contexte certains n'hésitent pas à
dénoncer des responsabilités politiques
dans cette hausse de l'antisémitisme en
France écoutez l'ancien Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe il y a depuis très
longtemps et il y a toujours eu une
forme d'an des formes d'antisémitisme en
France euh non attendez on en a toujours
eu mais l'attitude d'un certain nombre
de leaders actuel
euh à mon avis a une a pu décapsuler un
certain nombre de gens a pu finalement
donner le sentiment qu'on avait le droit
d'exprimer son
antisémitisme qu'on avait que c'était
quelque chose de d'acceptable
d'entendable voilà c'est une allusion à
peine voilée au propos polémique qui a
tenu Jean-Luc Mélenchon le leader de la
France insoumise depuis l'attaque du
Hamas contre Israël une responsabilité
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est également
pointée par François Hollande je ne
pense pas que Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour le
Bien Connaître soit un
antisémite mais je pense
qu'il par les positions qu'il prend
qu'il entretient un courant qui peut
devenir antisémite je crois quand il
s'est obstiné contre toute raison à ne
pas qualifier le Hamas comme une
organisation terroriste et à ne pas
qualifier les les les actes abominables
qui avaient été commis comme des actes
terroristes je pense qu'il a alimenté
finalement cette machine infernale et
dans ah mais allezy Alex non l'ancien
président de la République j'allais le
dire appelle les socialistes en tout cas
à rompre définitivement avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialist justement liig fort il
lance un appel à une initiative des
partis politiques contre l'antisémitisme
ça suscité un peu la polémique oui alors
son premier appel c'était hier
après-midi sur Radio J Olivier fort
appelait je cite toutes les forces
politiques à dire qu'il n'est pas
possible qu'il y ait le moindre acte ou
la moindre parole antisémite en France
une mobilisation qui pourrait prendre la
forme d'une grande marche et il le
disait le rassemblement national
national serait invité s'il veut bien
répondre à cet appel et faire en sorte
de couper avec sa propre histoire et une
partie de ses élus et cet appel incluant
le RN a suscité un tolé à gauche hier
hors de question pour de nombreux
responsables politiques de gauche de
marcher au côté du RN contre l'antisémi
car il n'oublie pas les propos du
fondateur du Front national Jean-Marie
Le Pen qui avait déclaré que la choie
était je cite un détail de l'histoire
alors quelques heures plus tard hier
Olivier fort a rétropédalé en affirmant
que le RN n'avait pas sa place dans ce
type de manifestation et il s'est
expliqué sur ce rétropédalage ce matin
sur notre plateau notamment après les
propos de Jordan Bardella sur Jean-Marie
Le Pen et cette fameuse citation le
détail de l'histoire il n pas fallu 4 He
pour que que en fait Jordane Bardella
malheureusement apporte la démonstration
que ce parti n'a rompu en rien avec son
histoire en rien avec ce qui a été
autrefois l'objet de sa condamnation
unanime qu'a-t-il dit il a dit
Jean-Marie Le Pen n'était pas antisémite
Jean-Marie Le Pen a été condamné
condamné par la justice à plusieurs
reprises preuve est faite qu'il ne
peuvent pas qu'il ne répondent pas aux
conditions que j'avais moi-même fixé qui
est de d'avoir une rupture claire nette
définitive
avec tout ce tous les liens qu'ils ont
pu entretenir avec la sphère antisémite
et la preuve a été donnée
malheureusement hier qu' n'ont rompu
avec rien Dominique en réaction à ces
propos deolivier fort et après on
parlera plus largement de ce que peut
faire les partis politiques sur cette si
j'étais si j'étais dans le style 4e
République je dirais qu'il se prend un
peu les pieds dans dans le tapis de il a
dit des choses un peu rapidement il les
rectifie et cetera voyons l'essentiel il
serait tant effectivement que l'ensemble
des forces en aujourd'hui en 2023
l'ensemble des forces politiques ou
alors elles font un choix dont il
faudrait tirer les conséquences se
dresse individuellement et
collectivement contre cette montée de
l'antisémitisme je suis atterré je
pardon je dis ça après d'autres et avant
d'autres j'espère enfin avant d'autres
dans d'autres émissions dans sur le
terrain et cetera je suis je suis
atterré je me pince comment est-ce
possible comment est-ce possible qu'en
France aujourd'hui on en soit à devoir
réunir les conditions d'une d'une lutte
contre l'antisémitisme comment comment
se fait-il que ça n'aille pas de soi com
comment se fait-il et puis
accessoirement mais moi je m'en fous
c'est pas c'est pas mon problème mais
comment se fait-il que on en soit encore
à traîner les les histoires de
Jean-Marie Le Pen du détail de
l'histoire il faut avoir ça en mémoire
hein c'est c'est c'est un un point
centrale de de de notre histoire
politique des des des 40 dernières
années mais comment se fait-il qu'on
soit encore condamné à se situer par
rapport à Jean-Marie Le Pen et son
détail de l'histoire non il y a il y a
quelque chose de il y a quelque chose de
poignant et de et et et surtout parce
que ça c'est c'est c'est
la c'est de de quelque chose
d'inquiétant
d'inquiétant que tout le monde fasse
bloc ou alors passe de l'autre côté mais
est-ce que tout le monde fait bloc c'est
ça la question vous avez entendu
François Hollande Édouard Philippe dans
des allusions à peine volé à la France
insoumise oui et je trouve assez
d'ailleurs paradoxal
que et en même temps c'est aussi le rôle
de la gauche he d'être à la hauteur de
ce moment-là parce que la gauche c'est
quand même le combat contre les les
discriminations son combat contre
l'antisémitisme son combat contre le
racisme c'est c'est à l'appel de la
gauche que le les mobilisations se font
historiquement d'ailleurs et que
là-dessus la droite et l'extrême droite
on entend pas beaucoup c'est vrai qu'on
a beaucoup accusé c'est le dossier de
cette semaine de politice la GAE pas sur
l'histoire de France parce qu'il y a une
gauchep
beau on a beaucoup accusé on a beaucoup
accusé ces derniers temps o en tout cas
soupçonné la gauche de d'être complice
ou d'avoir de de de de faire émerger une
forme d'antisémitisme mais l'histoire de
l'antisémitisme c'est quand même noué
prend ses racines dans les mouvements
d'extrême droite et aujourd'hui encore
très majoritairement euh donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que la gauche par parlez
quand même puisque c'est évident avec
cette historique parlez donc de de votre
position personnelle par rapport je
pense Dominique je pense que c'est
important de le rappeler quand même que
il y a quand même l'histoire de
l'antisémitisme trouve ses racines dans
l'extrême droite on pourrait parler de
ça et vousz Rais je trouve je trouve que
le sujet est suffisamment grave et les
accusations sont souvent suffisamment
récurrentes pour que la gauche
s'interroge sur son propre rapport au
peuple ou en tout cas aux populations
qui sont de confessions juives ça c'est
une certitude c'est pour ça qu'on a
choisi de faire ce dossier cette semaine
dans Politi c'est d'interroger sur
pourquoi la gauch rou commenttitude
actuelle de quelqu'un j'ai comme
journaliste suivi depuis 30 ans même
peut-être plus en 30 ans ou moins et et
et qui me Cid complètement c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'est-ce qui se
passe je je je je je pense en tout cas
c'est ça qu'on c'est ça qui doit qui
doit être interrogé et et je je pense
qu'il y a une partie je pense qu'il y a
une partie de la réponse dans l'histoire
récente c'est-à-dire que après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale la gauche a
considéré que l'antisémitisme était
derrière elle et que le combat qui était
devant elle c'était la question de
l'antiracisme et notamment de la cause
palestinienne et que à travers cette
défense de la cause palestinienne elle a
abandonné une partie de son combat
contre l'antisémitisme considérant qu'il
n'y avait plus d'antisémitisme que tout
ça était une histoire terminée donc je
pense que c'est làdessus qu'il faut la
gauche intéresse parce que moi jeis
d'acc'inroge mais donc elle a été
aveugle pendant un certain temps mais
mais elle était pas seule à être aveugle
je pense que tous tous nous celui quie
auourd'huianl
plusour de ce plateau il y a encore un
an 2 ans peut-êtreut plus tard plus tôt
dans notre dans notre histoire on se
serait dit qu'on aurait ce sujet à
débattre on Tom
laà ce que je veux dire notre société
elle est elle est collective après il
faut faire attention moi je suis je l'ai
même dit il y a y a 10 jours dans dans
Politi je je pense que la gauche doit
être à l'avantgarde de ça et doit doit
impulser une grande
marche il y a du boulot c'est certain
mais il faut le faire parce que moi
j'entends j'entends les Français de
confession juifes nous dire on ne se
sent pas soutenu on ne se sent pas
protégé on s il y a pas que vous qui les
ben non mais je l'entends et ça et ça m
meut et je me dis mais qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour que ces personnes
considèent qu'on est à leur côté que
jamais on ne les lâchera donc la
gaucheoser une mobilisation faire
commencer par rom avec les la seule
chose c'est faire ce que ce 1990 il
avait été fait avec François mitter en
première ligne une grande mobilisation
contre l'antisémitisme et je pense que
la gauche doit être à l'avant-garde en
tout cas à force de proposition ce qu' a
fait Olivier for est très bien mettons à
part la petite boulette la grosse
boulette mais qu' a remise en cause sur
votre plateau ce matin il faut une
grande marche sur l'antisme le peuple de
confession juive est inquiet pour son av
aujourd'hui en France je pense aussi aux
musulmans qui sont inquiets pour leur
propre avenir aussi en France il aussi
des condamnations qui doivent doivent
émaner aussi de notre
clementog merci merci à tous les deux
vous restez avec nous on regarde ce qu'
don au quotidien
[Musique]
régionau et Alex à la Une de La Provence
le début de l'examen du projet de
l'immigration et oui av tempête au Sénat
titre aujourd'hui la Provence alors que
le ministre de l'Intérieur géralde Manin
va défendre devant les sénateurs son
texte qui est censé allier fermeté en
facilitant les expulsions d'étrangers
délinquant et intégration par le travail
avec le fameux article 3 de
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension un
article qui ne plaît pas du tout aux
parlementaires les républicains et
précisément aux sénateurs qui refusent
pour l'instant de voter le texte en
l'état et cette mesure elle pourrait
faire échouer l'adoption du texte à la
fois au Sénat et aussi à l'Assemblée
nationale notre ministre va avoir une
journée chargée aujourd'hui il s'agit du
garde des saau Éric Dupont Moretti qui
se présente aujourd'hui devant la Cour
de Justice de la République pour son
procès c'est à la Une du journal
Libération champagne le procès d'un
ministre de la Justice en exercice c'est
une première dans l'histoire de la 5e
République Éric Dupont Moretti est
accusé d'avoir abusé de ses fonctions de
ministre pour régler des comptes avec le
parquet national financier qu'il avait
vivement affronté durant son passé
d'avocat le procès dure jusqu'au 16
novembre de nouvelles enquêtes sur la
maltrait dans les épades c'est à la Une
de La Dépêche du mil et oui 2 ans après
le livre choc de Victor Castanet sur ce
sujet deux nouvelles enquêtes ont été
publiées par 6000lions de consommateurs
et par la Fédération Nationale des
Associations de directeurs d'pad et
selon ces enquêtes plusieurs chiffres à
retenir 30 % des résidents d'pades
seraient victime de dénutrition
notamment car il refuse des repas qui
sont servis mixés 80 % des épades
manquent encore de personnel et à 50 %
des directeurs d'établissement
envisagent de démissionner rapidement ce
restaurant du Cher classé parmi
meilleurs du monde et oui il fait la une
du Berry Républicain aujourd'hui il
s'agit de la maison mdar qui est située
à boulerleray et qui vient d'être classé
4e meilleur restaurant gastronomique du
monde par l'application américaine trip
visor merci Alex pierre à la Une de
politise vous nous en avez parlé cette
question antisémite la gauche oui on
s'est entouré d'historien sociologue
pour essayer de comprendre justement ces
accusations ces soupçons très récurrents
et de remonter l'histoire pour
comprendre pourquoi la gauche doit
absolument s'interroger sur son rapport
à l'antisémitisme et c'est à lire cette
semaine dans Politis merci beaup et si
vous permtez j'ajouterai et la droite
aussi doit s' ce sera le prochain
dossier Pier merci beaucoup Dominique de
monvallon d'avoir été avec nous merci
Alex merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous à 16h vous suivez
en direct l'examen du projet de loi
immigration et à 22h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas H pour sens
public on se retrouve demain Alex très
bonne journée à
demain